(audience cheers and applauds)
- All right, y'all,
I wanna close out with one last story
that I hope will bring you a huge smile.
This is what I'm liking.
(jazzy music)
(audience cheers and applauds)
Earlier this hour we met Lacey
who's hanging out in our
Wayfair VIP Lounge right now,
and is gonna come to Vegas, right?
Yeah.
(audience cheers and applauds)
She's an elementary school educator
who also happens to be a
crazy, powerful vocalist,
like insane.
We love shining a light on
musical talent of all ages here
and all genres of music.
And just look at this
seven-year-old drummer
we discovered on TikTok.
(drums pounding and cymbals crashing)
- [Audience Member] Woo!
- [Audience Member] Yeah!
(drums pounding and cymbals crashing)
(audience cheers and applauds)
- I dunno if we discovered, but we found.
That's Ryder,
and he doesn't just play with kids, y'all,
Ryder has his very own band called
Ryder and the Masters
made up of all grownups,
and they play some of LA's
most iconic venues, seriously.
And, it's amazing.
We have Ryder and his dad,
Jason on the line now,
watching on NBC Los Angeles.
What's up, Ryder?
(audience cheers and applauds)
- What up, Kelly?
- Oh, my God, you're
so rock and roll, man.
All right, so Jason, how did
you discover Ryder's talent?
- I mean, from right away
he was all about the music,
and you know, we didn't realize
he was an actual musician
until he was about two,
and he was playing
drums on his high chair.
He played a very
recognizable Ramone's song,
and then within like the
week we got him a drum kit.
- That's incredible.
Let's see a little more
of Ryder in action.
- [Jason] Let's hear it.
(drums pounding and cymbals crashing)
(audience cheers and applauds)
- Like, what?
Ryder, you are so cool.
Oh, my gosh, like, what do
you love about drumming?
- Well, what I love
about drumming is like,
I love how it just, like, it
just comes from your heart,
you know?
It just beats you up,
and that's why it gives you
like the head bangs, you know?
(audience laughs)
And, it just like, it's crazy.
- Oh, my gosh, I cannot wait to see
where your life is headed.
You are so, so cool. Oh, my gosh.
Well, y'all have a big
gig next week, right?
- Oh yeah. Ryder B and the Masters
are playing at the Whisky A
Go Go on Sunset Boulevard.
(audience cheers and applauds)
- Oh, my gosh.
- We've got the posters back there.
- Yeah.
- Absolutely, Ryder, rock and
roll, little one. Oh, my gosh.
Thank you so much Ryder,
and thank you Jason.
Y'all have such a great
time at the Whisky.
I'm liking your post right now, all right?
- Yeah.
- Oh, I love that.
- I'm actually recording
a live album there,
my first album, live album.
(audience cheers and applauds)
- Oh, my God, that is so incredible.
We're gonna have to get you
to play at some point, Ryder.
Like, I'm gonna need to
feel that talent in person.
All right, well, that's not all,
actually our season
long partner Pilot Pen,
makers of FriXion, the go to erasable pen
of the Kelly Clarkson Show,
want to celebrate those
fearlessly pursuing music,
just like you rock stars.
So they're gonna give you a
thousand dollars to help out.
(audience cheers and applauds)
- [Ryder] What? A thousand dollars?
- Oh, my gosh. Thank you,
Ryder, thank you, Jason.
Thank you to all our guests this hour,
Leslie Jones, Ian Somerhalder, Moya, Cole,
Lacey, and Lawrence,
and y'all have a great day,
and if it's not, try and change it.